so when they start to come into the
market how do you think that they're
going to actually play this is we see
you know pimco is just one of many fixed
income asset managers okay let's buy
some equities that give us indirect
exposure they've been able to do that
now we've got this bitcoin features etf
eventually i'm assuming we'll get a
bitcoin spot etf i can go buy the assets
themselves i could allocate to a manager
and they can go do it like how do you
think about their entry point into the
market and then what is the um impact or
the pros and cons of each one of those
yeah it's a great question well first of
all i'm very disappointed i mean look as
somebody who is irresponsibly long
bitcoin and has most of his net worth in
bitcoin and abra stock anything that
promotes bitcoin i'm happy about
but you know the government is the
federal government i won't pick on the
states cause some of them are getting it
right the federal government is batting
a thousand when it comes to this stuff
they get it wrong every [ __ ] time
and and to create a
futures-based etf as the first product
i'm sorry it's just so dumb because the
average retail investor has no idea what
they're buying
if you explain to them like okay do you
know what contango means in terms of
what's happening their heads will spin
and these are the people i think it's a
dance move right it's the dance move
exactly and they just put up over a
billion dollars in this in 36 hours it
makes no sense right but that's the
overlords telling us that they're going
to protect us from ourselves
right as opposed to actually creating a
spot product where you can actually
audit the custody and and send in the
irs to do their bsa audits and whatever
it is that that they do to protect
retail investors and and create a damn
spot and i actually don't think we're
going to get a spot etf anytime soon
because i think they still believe
they're going to protect us from
ourselves which makes no sense okay so
put that aside
institutions that want to invest in
bitcoin don't need
securities markets to do it today
correct and and they're probably not
going to because of the inefficiencies
and the fees associated with it right no
large institution is going to pay two
percent
to to grayscale for for custodying
bitcoin most of the inflows to grayscale
i think uh and this is a testament to
the the product that they built was
because there was no redemptions there
was the premium and so people were
arbiting the premium and then once that
flipped that's where then all of a
sudden people say wait a second this
might not be the best way to get
exposure yeah and that was a big part of
the run-up last year just you know
intellectual honesty right i mean that
was definitely part of what was going on
uh but thank you barry yeah for sure you
know full disclosure he's one of my
first investors love barry great guy
great product very smart um but it's not
a good institutional product right i
mean there are very simple ways through
prime brokers now to get exposure if you
look at what you know sailor did micro
strategy i mean they don't disclose it
until afterwards because they don't want
to drive the price up because they want
to buy at the lowest price possible but
they're just spreading the orders around
prime brokers which is exactly what
tesla would do and all of these
institutions are literally they actually
publish not not lit like
not a figurative playbook they literally
publish the playbook on how to do it so
now these institutions know exactly
which prime brokers to go to they can
also work with companies like abra and
and block find others to actually borrow
against those holdings now which is
that's i think that's becoming the
mantra of how you replace fixed income
with bitcoin hold the appreciating asset
borrow the [ __ ] coin depreciating asset
and run your business that way that's
the future of fixed income now that's a
10 15 year transition that's just
starting this year yep right the idea of
what we're talking about would have been
impossible years ago the asset wasn't
worth enough to have any meaningful
borrow how do you think about these
people coming into the market with
trillions of dollars and bitcoin today
sitting at it you know near an all-time
high is this something where it has a
short-term impact or is the long-term
play well i still think we get those
kind of the volatility via futures
markets that the retail investors mostly
don't understand meaning
if there's so little bitcoin on
exchanges that everybody talks about
supply shocks will comes on talks about
supply shocks why the hell does the
price go down 20 on occasion right why
doesn't it just keep going up in a
straight line well you have this tension
between you know overbought futures and
and liquidations that happen and the
fact that you know spot basically has a
supply shock a permanent supply shock
now right i think what's going to happen
is as the price and the market cap goes
up
future's ability to have a
short-term
big impact on on pullbacks is going to
get diminished and then you're going to
basically see uh you know the price just
go up up up up to a point where even
stock to flow
and other kind of on-chain economic
models don't really do much anymore and
and that's when the floodgates are
really open because it becomes a
a negative feedback loop where
institutions are now going to be
motivated to buy because you're gonna
have a four trillion dollar asset a five
trillion dollar asset and all those
other metrics are gonna go out the
window futures won't matter anymore um
you know then it'll be about
macroeconomic black swan events you know
are we going is the united states going
to war with china that will drive pull
down pullbacks at that point when it
really does start to replace fixed
income and i think we're several years
away from that happening how high can
bitcoin's price go
well if it becomes the collateral
for the future of fixed income i mean in
today's dollars that's 100 trillion but
at that point i don't know if the
measurement in dollars matters anymore
we would measure bitcoin in bitcoin
right meaning this item costs this many
sats right at that point who cares what
a dollar is worth now
business may still use the dollar like i
think michael's sale and i we've talked
about this you know a few times i think
we disagree a little on this he thinks
the dollar is going to be around forever
i i'm not so sure
right um but you know at some point you
certainly can see it becoming the
collateral for all of these op debt
obligations which puts it in today's
terms at well over 100 trillion dollars
so that would put bitcoin uh no public
math but about five million dollars or
more a per bitcoin yeah you get to the
point where it's like on par sats are on
par with pennies and dollars right yeah
which is an order a couple orders of
magnitude from where we are now
so basically you're talking about if
bitcoin becomes the collateral for the
fixed income market everyone takes their
fixed income and says hey this is all
trash i'm gonna go and i'm gonna move to
this new asset when they do that if we
get to 100 trillion or so that comes
into the market where four and a half
five million dollar bitcoin price do you
think that's like a next five year thing
or that's like a 15 that's a 15-year
thing um it'll certainly replace
gold in market cap long before then but
that's not the big play that's that's
not the measuring or yardstick that
matters to me personally right because
to me it's about the future of the
internet having money for the internet
first and foremost and we're there now
right lightning is working um you know
and if you look at other crypto models
stable coins are working
um layer twos are working across the
board um we'll see if they scale quickly
or if it takes a few years but the
software engineers will figure it out
and then ultimately it's about dealing
with this this late stage debt cycle and
how we you know china is is worrying me
right now right and so how do we well i
mean if you look at the moves that
they're making in terms of you know just
pulling in capitalism uh you know
looking at how to manage resources
because i think that that the planners
the people who plan ahead there believe
that we're about to have a massive
resource supply shock on this planet and
they're preparing for a fight i really
believe that they think that the worst
case scenario is a fight over global
resources and if you look at the
investments they're making in africa and
other places we're asleep at the wheel
totally asleep at the wheel the u.s
europe nobody gets it right everybody's
fat and happy right now and not paying
attention to the big picture
and i hope that this global movement
towards decentralization that we're in
the middle of saves us but it's not
guaranteed
right